Nancy Cordes is inside the Senate
hearing room where the Attorney General
will be questioned today Nancy good
morning good morning this is actually
the first time that the Attorney General
will be testifying since he became
Attorney General this is probably not
the topic he had hoped he would be
talking about he's going to be going
before his former Senate colleagues who
have a lot of questions about him and
about Russia after commis testimony last
week in this same hearing room among the
things are going to want to know about
what was sessions role in commis firing
and was that appropriate given that
sessions had recused himself from the
Russia investigation an investigation
that the president says was on his mind
when he fired Comey they will also want
to know if there are any undisclosed
reasons as Comey hinted last week that
sessions had to recuse himself from the
Russia investigation now these senators
are prepared for the possibility that
sessions won't answer all their
questions that he will say that his
conversations with the president are
private just as two other top officials
the director of the National Security
Agency and the Director of National
Intelligence did in a similar hearing
last week but they probably will grill
him on what he thinks about this notion
of the president possibly firing the
special counsel Robert Moeller at least
one Republican Senator on this committee
Marco Rubio of Florida said yesterday
that he thinks that would be a big
mistake Charlie thanks Nancy